we're gonna do some resumption of action
pick it up in the bottom of the third
as yesterday's game was suspended and
we're gonna fire it up here today
very good start to this sunday for the
maritza one two three third
you'd like to keep something away from
him and invite him to pull it to the
right side
it's a bunt back to the mound kykel
has out number two
love the bunt two out look
if you're gonna bite on dallas kykel you
better make it a good one because he's
got four gold gloves
and there is no doubt he can pick it
[Applause]
tim it's short tough pick and
oh wow
they already got over there tim fed it
to him
and the mariners don't score goodness
how did they get it out
leary goes over tim stays right with it
not giving up on the play
and able somehow to get the ball to
second base
what a play
[Music]
mark rippinger right on the call he was
right there to see
the foot on the bag this is just a great
effort
man perfect reason to stay with a play
[Music]
two outs taylor trammell
fly ball you can't see it can't see it i
can't see it because it's out of here
that's why one-nothing mariners
taylor turmell with his seventh home run
one-nothing mariners in the fifth a big
two-out blast didn't waste any time
either
i guess for taylor his game plan was to
hit a first pitch fastball
that is beltai middle in
just throws the barrel at it top hand
coming off exit v low of 99 miles an
hour 372 feet
saw that universal distress signal from
uh
gonzalez where is it well it's behind
you now pal
three and two ball four
[Applause]
one and two over shortstop
in the center field mercedes
puts grandahl at second base
two on one out for garcia
by garcia joe mcewing waves around
grondol and the socks have tied the game
leori garcia a balloon to left
it's one all
he waits back on a change up just flicks
it into left field
so it's the bottom part of the order
getting the job done and bowers
not even close to the plate everything
is innocuous here
hector has no problem he's having a good
old time and he ends the glove and
everything is good with the glove but
then when they check the
inside of the glove
and it's ripperger and they're feeling
the inside of the glove going
whoa wait a second here this is our look
at the check from inside the glove
of phil cousy and mark riverton satiago
is the first person tab
for the extra substance check
and ejected from the ball game and the
mariners will be down a player for the
next 10 days and our understanding of
this
is as it gets checked out
see scott he was concerned about it and
you could just as the wheels are turning
thinking about losing a member of his
bullpen
maybe like so heavily on the bullpen
he's going to say maybe the best part of
his team
and a lot of success here's a fly ball
hit pretty well left center field
got some kerry and it's gone
home run time france 2-1 mariners here
in the sixth
home run number seven for ties 29th home
run this is right on the button exit
velo 106.
397 feet
that's a good poke good piece of hit
going out to get that pitch
it's goodwin monkatta and abreu coming
up and
goodwin first pitch hunting into right
field
[Applause]
clean pickup by haniger keeps him to a
single
sox have the lead off man aboard just
like in the fifth
that's fall fourth two on
nobody out and jose abreu
jose gets hit hope he's all right abreu
got drilled that got him on the side of
the knee and that
really hurts we'll watch it again
he can't get out of the way he's locked
in and it catches him right
off the side of the knee he's going to
need help to come off the field
and he also and they're going to take an
x-ray of it and
this is just a just a terrible sight
alabreyu out and the offense trying to
drum up
a lead yes to center field
tramell is back on it he squeezes the
first out
goodwin's coming home monkana to third
the sox have tied the game
on a sac fly from yasmani grande
[Applause]
a mark where it did hit in front of the
plane
gold shot into left lamb charging lamb
is there to snare it ankle high
[Applause]
there's the slider and he comes to make
the catch
taylor trammell home run one of the two
solo homers home run in the fifth
did he get another one looks like he did
and the mariners have a 3-2
lead taylor trammell at two home run day
and he's seen 98 a number of times and
here you go the breaking ball
87 miles an hour center cut exit v low
of 105 387 feet
and he knew it
with colin still at first he's going to
sink around the first pitch
to third seeger more at a double play
five to four to three the mariners
escape
three home run game for seattle and a
3-2
final score in game one of this double
header